welcome to this special edition of
hannity i'm tammy bruce in for sean
now tonight 2020 is almost in the books
and cnn's histrionic white house
correspondent jim acosta
has a very special new year's resolution
to the surprise of no one
acosta is vowing to take it easy on joe
biden
during an interview with the atlantic he
compared the trump white house
to a non-stop national emergency that
required a defiant response
acosta continued quote if being at the
white house is not an experience that
might merit
hazard pay then perhaps it is going to
be approached differently
in other words acosta will be rolling
out the red carpet for joe biden
there will be no russia hoax or
impeachment hysteria
or combative moments like this watch
david by the president's tongue
president's tone towards the press
obviously is not helpful at times and i
think that that's your liberty jim as
always
let me ask you a question hope to the
world for people to say
jim do you believe people to this
country jim and they're not always going
to speak english
do you believe he's going to be highly
skilled they're not always jim jim
jim i appreciate your speech i think we
saw the president's true colors today
and and i'm not sure they were red white
and blue
well acosta is just one small part of a
biased mainstream media mob
that has really almost no one trusts
them of course and for good reason
what we have witnessed over the last
four years has been an absolute
disgrace here are just a few examples
take a look
is this president trying to impersonate
hugo chavez
recep tayyip erdogan vladimir putin he
said today
america first it was not just the racial
i mean i shouldn't say racial the
hitlerian uh
background to it he's not of sound mind
you there do you
that's somebody that clinically you look
at and say there's something wrong there
trump needs to be medicated and
hospitalized
donald trump again being a schmuck we
can truly say his words have
absolutely emboldened white supremacists
he has given oxygen to racists
he is clearly trying to ignite a civil
war in this country his mind is dark
this is somebody in deep psychological
distress right now
as i'm watching this i'm thinking you
know fidel castro
julius caesar mabutu sessi seiko
that was not an american president
giving an acceptance speech
well tonight as we speak the same people
you just saw
are now switching gears instead of
attacking and investigating and probing
the media is now attempting to shield
joe biden from any and all negative
attention
for example you won't likely hear any
coverage of biden's near constant
confusion
like yesterday when joe called his
running mate kamala harris
the president-elect watch this
i hope the president will clearly and
unambiguously urge all americans
to take the vaccine once it's available
i took it to instill public confidence
in the vaccine
president-elect harris took it took hers
today for the same reason
while joe is measuring the drapes to the
oval office for his
president-elect kamala harris the fight
for election integrity does continue